[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Галичина,
Івано-Франківськ]
Класний такий кадр.
Там у нас ринок.
Отак будується майбутнє України.
[Юрій Филюк,
ініціатор проєкту «Промприлад.Реновація»]
Там справа всюди розкопки, бачите?
Проект називається «Промприлад. Реновація».
Ми намагаємось на базі отої частини
від величезного заводу
перетворити його на, такий собі, інноваційний центр
на перетині розвитку освіти, мистецтва,
нової економіки.
Ну і от, бачите, наш логотип.
Власне, запрошую
Це зараз є пілотний поверх,
тут 1800 квадратних метрів.
Ми, станом на сьогодні,
взяли його в довгострокову оренду
і за свої кошти вже привели в порядок.
От дві є дитячі розвиваючі функції:
«Робоклуб» і «Дрібнота».
Тут відбувається неформальна освіта дітей
в напрямках бізнес, архітектура, наука,
робототехніка, комп'ютерна грамотність і так далі.
Тут, що цікаво,
це Департамент інвестиційної політики
міськвиконкому.
Нам вдалось їх переконати,
що, власне, їхнє місце тут.
Тут їхній клієнт, а не там в цій «великій білій хаті».
Тобто тут є бізнеси, є громадські організації
і є представники адміністрації.
Власне, ми маємо багато спільних проектів
в різних таких колабораціях.
Тут у нас ще є денс скул (школа танців).
Розкажи трошки про те, що ви тут робите, де ми є.
Ми тут танцюємо в нових залах —
супермодних, суперкласних
і комфортних, найосновніше для нас.
[Вікторія Ковальчук,
викладачка танців]
Я так розумію, це ж зараз, напевне,
єдиний повноцінний зал танцювальний
з роздягалками, з усією інфраструктурою,
з правильним паркетом.
Ну я вважаю, що так.
Тому що, навіть судячи з тих залів, які в нас є,
саме в нашому місті,
мало в яких залах є навіть душові.
Тобто, для Франківська, це можна сказати,
що розкіш, в якомусь плані.
Сам проект ми робили, власне,
за всіма останніми канонами енергоефективності.
Ми не використовуєм газ,
тільки електроенергію, нічний тариф.
Таким чином, ми, в середньому, мінімум, в 4 рази
енергоефективніші за будь-які новобудови
середньостатистичні, які будують.
Це теж було важливо.
Ну і, власне, тут можна подивитись на сам завод.
Завод діючий,
він має близько 160-ти працівників.
Власне, ідея полягає в тому, що він має бути
нерозривним в своїх як економічних задачах,
так і в соціальних трансформаційних задачах.
Тому все будується
на принципах спільного фінансування
і половина проекту буде належати
некомерційному неприбутковому фонду
однойменному «Промприлад»,
а половину вартості, власне, інвестицій
ми «викидуємо» на вільний ринок
у вигляді цінних паперів
і будь-хто може купити долю, фактично,
цього великого бізнесу, стати співласником.
Це різна креативна економіка,
інноваційна економіка,
яка, в цілому, покликана допомогти остаточно
місту перезавантажитись
з пострадянських контекстів у сучасні.
Ну і, фактично, поставити Франківськ
на світову мапу.
Видно процес трансформації.
Тут іде зараз ремонт 2-го поверху.
Ну і туди трошки можна побачити теритрію заводу.
Сусіди тут теж забудовуються.
І, в принципі, ми усвідомлювали, що
якщо зараз не зайти і щось не зробити
з цією ділянкою, то її, фактично,
так само забудують таким традиційним житлом.
Але якого і так зараз дуже багато.
Власне, не вистачає
якихось інфраструктурних елементів,
які б створювали додану вартість,
окрім, споживницького житла.
Тому ми, власне, і взялись за цю амбіцію.
Пацани, привіт!
Можна вас потурбувати?
Просто показую що є на «Промприладі».
Розкажи два слова,
чому ви сюди вирішили переїхати.
[Андрій Черніков,
IT-фахівець, співінвестор]
Ти ж бачив бар?
Бар?
Ну короче, бар все вирішує.
Бар «рішає».
Просто тут подобається.
Андрій ще й один з інвесторів «Промприлад».
Розкажи чого ти сюди гроші вклав.
Не починай.
Тому що, нема куди гроші вкладати в цій країні.
Розкажи про свій біль, про квартиру.
Про квартиру?
В двох словах, інвестуйте в «Промприлад»,
не купляйте квартири.
Та класно, тому що хочеться більшого,
хочеться якісь нормальні умови праці.
Тут вони, в принципі, надаються.
Добре, дякую
Продавати комерційну нерухомість,
вона довше повертається,
а тут воно побудовано на ринку заробітчан.
Заробітчани, ну власне, для них —
це єдиний доступний зрозумілий
інвестиційний інструмент — купити квартиру
дітям, а потім ще одну на здачу, наприклад.
І, за великим рахунком, це бульбашка,
яка, рано чи пізно, просто трісне.
Ну ринок мудрий,
він завжди все сам вирівнює, рано чи пізно,
але, просто, не хочеться щоб це було через колапси.
І от ми хочемо спробувати якраз дати альтернативу
під теж саме інвестування, тобто дати,
такий собі, інструмент куди можна вкласти кошти,
причому, в різному об'ємі,
від 1 000 $ до 1 000 000 $.
І який  буде теж мати економіку,
але плюс, окрім того, ти робиш дуже хорошу справу,
тому що, створюючи такий проект,
тут ще велика додаткова капіталізація виникає
у всіх, хто живе у цьому місті, у цьому районі,
тому що, вона починає розвиватись активніше.
Це коворкінг.
Нас часто питають:
«Коли ви будете стелю ремонтувати?»
Ми пояснюємо, що збереження цього індастріалу
це дуже важливо.
І, власне, ми зараз ще більше думаєм про те,
як підкреслити не просто індастріал,
а саме цей українсько-радянський індастріал
як унікальність саме цього району,
щоб тут відобразити на рівні проекту.
Нам здається, що вже прийшов час
генерувати ідеї назовні, експортувати.
Все вже зараз є в Україні для цього.
Дуже крутий час, насправді.
Людям зрозуміло що таке благодійність.
Умовно: віддати десятину на щось там благодійне.
І люди розуміють, що таке комерція.
А як воно до купи з'єднується, це трохи складно,
але в тому і краса.
Впродовж наступних 1.5 роки ми маємо
повністю, за графіком, викупити завод існуючий
і далі вже піде реконструкція наступних корпусів,
наповнення всіма функціями, крок за кроком.
Успіх цього проекту відкриває як в Україні
великі потенціали, тому що нема нормального
фондового ринку, станом на сьогодні,
а в людей є потреба.
І це так само може виводити, власне,
інструмент системного вирішення
якихось суспільних складних задач
вже не лише в Україні
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Максим Завалля]
[Продюсека
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Valeriia Kuznetsova]
[Музика
Marsbeing]
[Субтитрувальниця
Катя Батлер]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]